[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier transform and in the last
lecture we introduced the discrete
Fourier transform or the DFT which is a
way of taking the Fourier transform of
vectors of data so instead of having an
analytically defined function I just
have data defined at endpoints in some
interval and if I have that data stacked
into a vector I can compute the discrete
Fourier transform or the DFT by matrix
multiplication with this vandermonde
matrix the DFT matrix that we derived in
the last lecture now this is very useful
this allows you to Fourier transform
data and break down your data into
frequency components sums of sines and
cosines and in this lecture I'm gonna
tell you how to do this in a
computationally fast and efficient way
using the fast Fourier transform or the
FFT so the FFT has changed the world
this is one of the most important
algorithms ever developed and it is the
enabling piece of technology in most of
digital communications audio compression
image compression satellite TV you name
it the FFT is at the heart of this this
computation okay and so the FFT has
essentially become synonymous with the
DFT you never compute the DFT without
using the FFT algorithm so the FFT is
kind of the algorithm that you use to
compute the discrete Fourier transform
okay and so in principle you don't
actually ever build this matrix or or
multiply this matrix by this vector you
do something a little bit more clever
that's much faster so I'm gonna in this
lecture I'm gonna walk you through why
we need the fast Fourier transform
I'll give you a little bit of an idea of
what the FFT is how it works
and then I'll kind of intro some of the
applications we're going to apply the
FFT to in in the next few few videos
okay so the real reason we need the FFT
is speed or efficiency okay so the DFT
calculation is what we call an order N
squared calculation so this is the
notation order N squared which means it
I have n pieces of information in my
data vector when I multiply that by this
n by n matrix each row times column
multiplication is n multiplications and
I have n of those rows so there are n
squared total multiplications I have to
perform to do this discrete Fourier
transform matrix multiplication okay now
that's pretty expensive as n gets bigger
and bigger so when we think about audio
signals or images this int n might be
quite large and this would be an
expensive or a slow computation whereas
the FFT achieves the exact same Fourier
transform these give exactly the same
output but the fast Fourier transform is
order n log N and this is a so-called
fast scaling it's almost linear in n
there's just the small correction of log
n in the scaling and what's nice is that
log n becomes less and less important
the bigger that n gets okay so if I have
n as a thousand this might be three but
when n is a billion this is only nine
okay so this doesn't get that big that
fast with n so this is almost linear
scaling and n which is much much bigger
than quadratic scaling in n okay and so
just to give you kind of an idea of this
if I was trying to use the Fourier
transform to compress 10 seconds of an
audio signal and audio is sampled at
something like 44 kilohertz so 10
seconds would be I'd have an N of about
40 for 440,000 so four point four times
ten ten to the fifth okay that would be
for a 10 seconds of audio then to
compress that using the discrete Fourier
transform would amount to approximately
10 to the 11 multiplications that's a
hundred billion multiplications whereas
the fast Fourier transform would be much
much smaller it'd be something like
closer to ten to the six matrix
multiplications okay this would be
billion multiplications this would be
about a million multiplications for the
exact same 10-second audio clip just to
compute the Fourier transform okay so
you can see right off the bat that the
fast Fourier transform in this case is a
hundred thousand times faster and more
efficient okay if we were stuck doing
the discrete Fourier transform we
wouldn't have the same kind of image and
audio compression that we have today we
wouldn't be able to send pictures you
know seamlessly across continents and
have streaming television and all of
this would be much much harder because
this scaling here is not that favorable
but this scaling order n log n is really
really good scaling okay so the FFT was
invented by Cooley and Toki you can read
a little bit more about the history in
databook UW comm but in the last century
there were lots of specialized fourier
transform algorithms and the fast
Fourier transform that we know today was
kind of the culmination of all of those
algorithms
in the middle of last century okay
now interestingly Gauss actually
invented a form of the fast Fourier
transform hundreds of years ago around I
think 1806 because he was doing mental
calculations that required a Fourier
transform and he realized that these
were were too slow or too cumbersome
with kind of the DFT algorithm and so he
invented the FFT but he didn't think it
was worth worth publishing there weren't
you know computers at the time so it was
just kind of a mental math algorithm for
him okay so the fast Fourier transform
is how we compute the discrete Fourier
transform it's the algorithm that is
efficient and useful for for real
signals audio and image I'll give you a
little bit of an idea of how this is
computed but first I might tell you a
bit about why we're gonna do this so
we're going to use the FFT so the uses
of the FFT and there are so many I can't
list them here I'm just going to tell
you the examples I'm going to show you
so just like the regular Fourier
transform we can use the fast Fourier
transform to compute derivatives
so we can approximate derivatives and we
can then use those derivatives to solve
PDE s so in my field of scientific
computing this is a big deal we use the
fast Fourier transform to solve
numerical PDE is really complicated
spatial-temporal PDE s that describe
real-world world phenomena and because
of this favorable scaling we can solve
really really big problems okay
so that's that's one major application
another is to denoise data okay so if
you have noisy data you might be able to
filter some of that noise out if it's at
certain frequencies using this fast
Fourier transform so we would take our
data Fourier transform kill some of the
may be high frequency terms that have
noise and then inverse fast Fourier
transform so denoising data in general
just data analysis is a big deal
analysis of data and then one of the
things I'm going to show you that I
think is incredibly powerful is the use
of the FFT for audio and image
compression
so just compression in general and
especially I'm going to show you
examples in audio and images okay and in
the modern era we actually do something
called a wavelet transform or a fast
wavelet transform that's kind of for
enhanced image compression but again
it's still built on this fast Fourier
transform algorithm okay so this is
really the engine driving all of these
these applications okay so I think in
the next short video I'm gonna give you
just a flavor for how we can get away
with this scaling by bypassing this big
matrix multiplication and doing
something a little bit smarter instead
and then I'm going to code up some
examples for for all of these bullets in
MATLAB and in Python alright thank you